you heard a little bit of myself so
these are the list of
Frances I I did not plan to
all of them it happened but accidentally
but it's also like a lot of fun actually
working on a program and little speakers
in the community so I like to get around
a little bit about becoming a company
I'm one of the partners at KU next week
so we are a very diverse and
heterogeneous cheap so we serve like
consultancy and data science project we
work with startups but we can also help
companies with communication so it's
like the super rule yeah but that's I I
love it it's just like very nice to talk
but we would never work on all these
different levels with great people so
enough about myself what's your
background
so who's the data scientists okay this
is only 50% data scientists here okay
interesting who's a database admin Wow
two people yes okay who's more like a
purist Python mister okay and who's a
consultant decision maker or IT
executive or YouTube influencer okay
cool
I had expected more data scientists
actually well that's right um so what's
your experience a relational databases
cool quick left to save some time okay
weird about it no SQL systems okay look
at that
so um Hadoop and sparks and everything
around it so okay okay I see I see you
did like 50% have knowledge and
religious databases on on like 10
present on Noyes girl and how to so
that'sthat's great
because we can we can really build up on
that um so what are you looking for um
it's more like let me answer the
question for you because we've to save
some time so because this basically free
angles to look on databases for data
science um is choosing a database for
your data science project um and
evaluating an existing system for data
for your data science requirements and
how to integrate into an existing
ecosystem because if you start working
at a company you cannot say oh i i like
this database can you please change your
infrastructure
how did I actually come up with the idea
actually it was Emma oh you didn't see
that coming
actually she asked me last year can you
do something on ask you all SQL tutorial
for your psyche hi
and I said why because I come from more
like I used to work a lot of databases
and I came all from databases and
building applications to data science
and deep learning in all the stuff so
for me it was natural to use a database
to support anything I was doing in data
science and answers okay there seems to
be a gap and I thought about it and I
thought okay yeah maybe it's um maybe
there's a gap because if you see
tutorials from universities and online
it's almost everything is file based you
hardly hear of a database at all so
there's a gap so and if I want to see
what basically the stereotypes are I
asked usually I asked Google so what is
the database scientists and database
admin and what might they have in common
have mccomber so let's check the Google
search and we see the database like oh
no sorry that's the data scientist here
you see all like many people with
glasses and heroes and basically this is
the data scientist stereotype the
database admin stereotype according to
google picture search is more like these
guy with like standing in front of
servers and stuff and looking important
but it's more like quite quite nerdy I'd
say so basically looks like this
and I'll continue when I have you to
hear the first loves okay let's continue
so this this talk is about unfilled on
some research and experience ah from me
colleagues people who I spoke to after
giving this talk it's supposed to give
you a guideline on choosing a system
which might need which would help you so
this is definitely one of the talks
tools you should know and tools you
should be aware about aware of in for
data science um and I also have to do a
disclaimer some of these ratings are
subjective it's not about the ratings
it's more about like the process so yeah
so let's let's walk so what are the data
Bay there every benefits of a database
for data Sciences anyway so you have a
common source of data so you don't have
to share files and look what's the last
the most recent version you can avoid
redundancies or the files you have
persistence they're optimized for
handling and accessing data for decades
I mean databases are really old they're
like they're all I go work for 40 years
the scalability and also since you can
have operations really close to the data
on a database system so this is like a
quick recap on database history so in
the 60s we had like navigational the
database so some distant drum so this is
what you see in all science fiction
movies was like this rotating pings and
big labs like these all supercomputers
and put in the 70s I would argue or
databases got seriously with relational
database systems and 80s databases moved
to the desktop or in the 90s they got a
big object orientated and in the 2000s
we had the whole know SQL movement so
let's start with the inventors or the
relational databases they were the first
so they have to be noticed first so the
relational database I think most of you
know records are organized
cables so there's roles of the tables
and they all are interconnected by
unique case um the data Li the data is
ideally normalized so you don't have any
redundancies in the data
um and the data or can be denormalized
for real for performance we look at that
later and the transactions are asset so
what to do atomic consistent isolated
and durable so basically I I'd say a
relational database is always like the
truth there's only one truth and you
will find it in a relational database
and this is one of the big gaps to not
only sequel systems we will see later so
this is just like a little catch-up so
you see there's a lot a lot a lot of
databases um around here um so and how
they basically are if they interact so
you could look at the database history
also like this and this is just like the
relational database systems and this is
log how this works how do people decide
on in your database it looks like this
so nobody thought that was fine okay so
yeah relational database the benefits
are they are widely used and supported
they were are well researched um they
have a very comprehensive current
language the SQL language is like very
common language and it's actually like
the mother of many querying languages so
it's it's really well researched and
optimized and basically to take a little
visualization of relational database
system this is like this you see the
tables and they're all connected by keys
and this is like just like one example
and they also they may look like this as
well if you have a system which is just
a little bit bigger or it must look like
this and this is actually where we come
to the downsides one of the downsides is
the schemas are fixed you have to define
everything upfront so and also have to
note there are probably some specialist
systems which are a little bit lacks on
that so I'm generalizing a bit to give
you like the an overview um so you have
to basically decide a lot of stuff up
front which is probably totally
irrelevant for your project um and this
is like a real pain actually this was
the main reason that drove me to using
no SQL systems because I had a web
scraping project and I just wanted to
save the data and not worry about the
schema and whatever what I want to PEX
actually store in the system in the very
beginning actually I want to store stuff
in the system work on it and drain
knowledge from that and not worry about
schemas so the relational database
systems are like a schema first arm
system on day and so altering a schema
is not trivial or you may know like
database admins are not the super
popular people in yes in enterprises but
don't blame them they also have depend
to defend this schema like M if you look
at the schema like this and you have a
whole enterprise with all the enterprise
needs and most likely work everything's
working you have to be really careful
before you change a schema because it
might destroy stuff for others so it's
it's don't
them for being like defenders of a
schemer so it's difficult to scale off
because it's given this schemer and
there's only like few data structures
like tables and rows um so this why
people came up with the know SQL types
like or know SQL databases so these are
like them there are multiple types of
SQL no SQL types and it's not no against
SQL it's not only SQL that's how we read
it nowadays
so we're key value stores which is like
very simple key value um which is
probably not so super useful for a
bigger data science project and we've
document databases and adjacent style so
you can have like a JSON file and
basically you can store a dictionary in
a database from the person perspective
and we have these white column databases
and they they look like a Eurasian
database from the outside but they
aren't um so the columns on a fix
they're also like really flexible and
can be really very efficient on huge
data sets and there's a graph databases
so there's like three for more types and
three of them are but I feel relevant
for us to know SQL database benefits are
there is no need to normalize there's
nothing you need to decide upfront you
can maintain
klopse complex data structures so you
can basically store multi-dimensional
data in a document based database
without defining anything upfront
it supports data sharding because since
the data is not as torn apart as in a
relational database it's really easier
to spread the information across
multiple servers and and have a really
reliable scaling system here which can
have like the benefits of more security
our maybe scalability and of course
performance um so and there's of course
new ways to query all this so um the no
SQL place where they also have downsides
so the shiny thing is it's not almost
like the best you know deep learning we
learnt it today all the audio in
conference um
so there's a concept of eventual
consistency which I would argue is not a
real problem for database something
because the data will be eventually come
on system and it can be like
the second milliseconds and it's not
like it's not because like it depends on
your mother language actually in Germany
eventual is more like yeah maybe yeah
but it's not maybe it's just it's
happening it's just like a matter of
time when this is going to be happening
your flexibility requires more
responsibilities for example we have
open schema so you don't need to define
a schema upfront before you can add data
for example into a document store like
MongoDB but of course your reliability
is okay if you want to store an integer
you have to store an integer and you
have to make sure in your code you store
an integer because the relational
database editor normal SQL database
might not force you there are tools to
force that but I think that's not
practical so it's also like
responsibilities are moving but I think
it's nice because you can actually look
at everything in your code and you don't
need to look into the database for that
so a quick bird's-eye view on we've
learned about relational databases and a
no SQL databases so let's have where do
we stand actually so this is a
screenshot I have taken from DB engines
comm and highlight it just like the top
10 you probably might really we have
Oracle no SQL Microsoft SQL PostScript
MongoDB db2 Redis Cassandra HBase and
Amazon's diamond no DynamoDB are
according to this site's ranking which
is probably both the only ranking but I
think it's a good ranking you see okay
well you see you like the players there
and then the new players basically come
from 2013 to 2018 so there's a constant
movement no SQL is getting more and more
popular but we do we stand if we split
the whole thing and they also assign
points on the relevance or like the you
how often the databases are used and
this is a clear picture that relational
databases they are very dominant so this
is oracle mysql microsoft SQL and
actually this is Postgres this is the
first open source also what - girls
so open-source day but they tend to
change the open-source license sometime
sometime so so yeah we see there's still
a big dominance in the relational
database systems to Renault let's go we
have to take two things into into
account of course no SQL systems are
pretty new there's only 10 years and
there's like 40 years and of course once
as a larger Enterprise has settled for
one system they will you cannot just
like plug and play and change database
system so they will be there for quite
some time because companies don't change
that quick but yeah so there's like two
consistency models of databases I've
already mentioned acid and and there
they did counter concept from NoSQL is
base you see this is little little made
up because acid and base it goes so well
together so well this is basically make
many people from relational database to
have big problems with base and
especially also like to cap theorem that
data may eventually become consistent
and also from schema design it can give
you a headache actually the first year I
worked with the knowledge skill I had
this little bird and my back of my brain
and said this feels doesn't feel right
because when I was thinking about data
structures and databases I hacked is
like picture of tables and in my mind
and I had to change it and you know like
changing routines can be a little bit
they work on one second stick kicking in
and focus but it was totally worth it to
ignore the little bird and and move
there so let's do some comparison so
what open source so since we are an open
source community and I think we should
favor open source software so these are
like this is like the open source check
you see there's like open source you see
also like there's a lot of mixture
models this and community edition or an
open source database like MongoDB but
they also offer professional support for
money because of course they have to
live from something as well Laura
Cassandra is also open source it's windy
path pati stack but there's also
companies who provide professional
server
around it yeah and yeah it's and then
one thing Amazon DynamoDB is of course
only a database as a service is only
available in the Amazon Cloud for
example so I settled for the following
contenders being a representative of the
types we see um so we have PostgreSQL
for the duration database systems
MongoDB is a document stock center a
full white column store and new for
Jaipur graph just a little catch up on
that
so we've seen relational database system
so tables and multiple tables
interconnected by keys is a database a
document orientated database stores
Chasen like objects so basically imagine
like yeah Jason I think everybody knows
Jason here I'm talking him yeah great
multiple of these binary JSON documents
basically are a collection and multiple
collections arguing a database so and
usually you keep the data schema and how
your jason files looks like very similar
here in the collections I mean it's not
like doing your taxes and a big shoebox
or something like that it's it's it's
basically you have quite consistent
schemers here as something is which is
very often misunderstood do you have a
collection just put anything of course
you want to have similar stuff in there
because otherwise you have to query the
stuff you are looking for cassandra is a
different system and its really that
might take some time until you can get
your head around it's a web it still
like we have rows and columns but we
store them in a vertical way which is
like my so basically like to make it a
little bit easier you you store like
keys and you have the columns here and
they the protocols might change from
time to time ah and Cassandra is also
like a little bit you can imagine it
like a system with like many no it's
called interconnecting and finding each
other um so these systems can really
grow it's very like a peer-to-peer
system and cassandra is the only
database I'm aware of which is faster in
in writing then reading because usually
it's the other way around
so our graphs I think everybody's aware
of graphs so a graph database is again
we have like nodes and they are
basically then they have connections and
they can also have notes can have
attributes and so basic the graph so you
see this is totally different setup here
so a quick look on the cap theory
theorem this basically the cap theorem
says you can have only like two you can
only guarantee for two of these but not
all of them at the same time so there's
always like a trade-off and you see like
the different no SQL systems or systems
settled for one of the two so let's make
a start making a choice how hard we
trying now to ask the right questions to
make a good selection for in the context
of data science so how hard is it to
collect data and the ration database
system it depends on a schema complexity
actually um so and especially if you
have multiple data sources so you have
to think quite some time
how will the how will the data look like
and adapt the schema for that in MongoDB
is quite easy because you have to have
these documents structures and you can
just like half the stuff put the stuff
in there in Cassandra um you have to be
pretty fine stuff as well but I would
also argue it's it's easy once it's
being set up and on u4j I'd argue yes
easy as well well you have to put in a
graph so you basically have the only
stores graph it cannot store anything ah
like that like not everything without
setups should be wrong data retention
actually is also a little bit different
so and what about data types because
it's it's important because a classic
for me at least in my experience with
systems is oh you get data from outside
you read them from an XML or some
outside so also web scraping and you
store and it's it happens really easy
you store a string you want to store an
integer but you store
a string because the data source changes
or you've just missed it and the code on
the data cleansing so you can enforce
how can you enforce the data types
because we want to have clean data types
in our database because they are a tool
they should help and support us than the
data science projects so part of a cost
we have to preform a schema so this is
very enforcing basically MongoDB it's
possible you can do it in the code but
you can also like have one MongoDB
handle it on warning or not allowing and
sum of anything which is not the mature
effects which are excluded before in the
data types Cassandra yes you have to
come up with schema before as well and
then G u 4j yes and parenthesis because
yes of course but graphs and graph stuff
only the flexibility in the data types
basically I think there's a Postgres SQL
this has also in know SQL feature I want
to mention so you can have like extra
attributes and adjacent like format as
well stored in SQL hey in a post press
SQL and of course you can also enforce
it and yeah basically that's that's a
big overview here um how hard is it to
consolidate data basically yeah of
course with the rest your database
system you have to build a schema up
front in the moment EB because you can
basically shovel stuff in and
consolidate later I think I would argue
it's quite easy
ah because it's a two-step process and
not anticipating something in looking
later process and Cassandra um it's it
depends a lot on the partitioning I've
mentioned like the Cassandra clusters
can be become really huge and you have
to manage them so it depends on the
cluster actually and you need for J I
will just like say yeah yes because like
that's the database is built for graphs
and handling big graphs um same for
missing data like similar for missing
data for example like in a document
store you can basically just shuffle
data in and have like data cleansing
validation look for missing data decide
on how you want to
the missing data or dirty data you can
make it a two-step process because it's
quite simple we have the document and
you can just like say okay you just add
another attribute to your document
stores that okay this has been processed
and it's busy approved and true and then
you can basically make it to two-step
process which can be helpful because
first look at the data and then make the
decisions persisting a clean dataset is
easy in all all of them once you've made
it you pull through like they okay it's
obvious the database is there for
persisting data so this is easy in all
systems next question how hard is it to
write against current databases because
I mean it's great to have a data store
but you also doesn't need to talk to it
so on the languages we see a force
concept well is SQL so basic queries are
easy I think everybody should know basic
SQL language because also for the other
reason for example like Cassandra is csq
oh but it's very similar to SQL and also
cipher from the foj is very similar it's
all like very similar and SQL context so
SQL was like the mother for many other
querying languages so they are quite
easy to learn and to do knowledge
transfer here MongoDB has a mmmm QL
which is also not too difficult actually
features two ways you can directly
create database and but it also has like
an aggregation framework which is
specialized for data aggregation and
this is a little different to the rest
of the SQL language
well the concepts are basically very
similar so it's not too hard to adapt
advanced queries on ask you oh I would
argue can become hard because you really
need to think in sets and you need to be
aware of how to add who to to do joints
we have a look later as well the MongoDB
you can build a little bit up on a
system Cassandra basically it's the same
with once you'd go into a SQL space it
becomes hard once thing stuff becomes
complex and I'll show you why in a bit
so how hard is the
wearing to learn I would say it's all
easy to medium once in your basic
queries and the advanced stuff it can
become hard but I argue for most if you
collect data and want to store them in a
database to help you to have like an
assistant for data science project you
probably will stay in the basic query
space yeah so you just not to have to
worry too much about it
about like advanced queries but it
depends on the structure so then know
that SQL benefits and downsides we have
a common standard it's long established
it's well researched it's the mother of
many other query languages and it has a
set based logic and if you can think in
sets it's great it's very helpful um
complexity increases fast badly designed
joins so what the join if we have like
multiple tables and we want to basically
join the data together again they can
also drink performance if they are badly
designed so if you do a lot of joins in
a huge system it can become difficult
you can also basic it it caalso drained
performance from their system the
overhead understanding a large schema
can be it takes some time especially if
not well documented so and also set
based logic can be also like a downside
if you don't like set based logic so
this is a simple SQL query so select an
employee some some attributes from a
table called employees and a hired a
this is like super simple this is
basically just the human asking a
question but this is not really super
complex but you see already it can
easily be it's not really readable
because we have to see okay this is like
an inner join we select something here
how does this play together and it's not
really readable and just like one minute
you need some time and you need more a
lot of knowledge about the system to
understand that
in Cassandra it's very simple this is a
simple Cassandra query you see it's very
very similar to SQL neo4j
it's also like a simple neo4j query you
see all like the match and optional
stuff is a little bit different but you
see still like this is the sto mindset
behind it
long would you beat this stuff a little
differently because they have a pipeline
concept so basically we have like a
match then we get data back and then we
have a dataset and we work on this data
set sorted do a grouping and just count
for something yeah and a date how many
releases on the date and do a projection
to get um data out um so and these
aggregation pipelines a little bit
different because like you basically
pass on data to the next stage so
they're a little bit easier to develop
because you can develop them step by
step and see the outcome so it's quite
handy so how hard is it to run because
like being a database admin is maybe not
your the dream come true but how can you
basically set up a database in your own
ecosystem without having too much
trouble um so the setup actually is
quite easy for all of them or if you for
example work on a Mac you can use
homebrew to install them and it's it's
it's crazy
um maintenance is yeah it depends of
course on the complexity and then the
reads writes and deletes and stuff so
it's also like handable on so if you
have a huge Cassandra cluster it can
become intense because Cassandra thus
write new stuff when you delete
something or like it's it's like it's
optimized for sequential reading and
writing and backup it depends on your
backup strategy ah so of course it's
quite easy to replicate NoSQL systems
because you have like a primary server
like one basically our phone master or
like like one one one database and other
just making copies of the data
and of course this is quite easy to make
backups from this because you have these
siblings and you just can take one
sibling off and store it somewhere and
bring it back up online again and that's
it's solvable also in the relational
database systems and of course they also
like trying to catch up now so it's not
impossible but maybe more complex and
maybe only with a commercial solution
how hard is it because one main
questions how hard is it eran analytics
especially without affecting the
performance of the production system so
again here is quite similar with the
backups so no SQL systems you can't have
like extra copies and servers and you
can just say for example in Agra media's
like you can have like a hidden node so
this is like a replica set which copies
data from the system over but it does
not take part in loads it will never
become the primary you can write on so
basically it's a backup system you can
have like your desk computer if you have
enough space and a nice connection and
just work your analysis on there without
affecting any of the production system
so that's that's quite nice and not
cause like relational databases you
probably want to work on a nightly
backup or like a copy here just like an
example on horizontal scaling so we just
saw what we call horizontal scaling and
no SQL systems and the other is vertical
scaling so this is basically your
charting so how we have different we
tear apart the data apart basically
imagine if it is also phonebook so this
was a 2d and this was baby lee as to
that for example so we have some key
splitting the data and of course you can
have more servers and power involved and
this is also like helpful for
performance and of course you can also
like combine both of them yeah
so if you already is there an existing
systems
I'd say it's quite easy to add them to
an existing system so if your company
manager or somebody in your company
it's impossible with other databases to
May it's actually easy to add because
it's just like another database system
it's not that you have to fully
integrate it into all the processes of
your company so it's it's it's fairly
easy I'd argue um to access and change
these systems and authorization um I
probably think if it's just like an
extra database for data science project
this is not the major issue but of
course enterprises have to take care of
who has access to the data what all
databases have decent systems to have
user or role based access to up to field
level or at least collection level and
so I think this should be um fair enough
for that to add new data so if something
new comes on how can you basically add
it um it depends again on this kiss on
the on the schema of the relational
database systems and with the others
it's I'd say easy no your JS of course
graph data only here um and I think this
is one of the major points for data
science projects actually how hard is it
to understand the data structure and
this is I think in a small system it's
easy
anyway simple tables and put documents
but once the data structures become more
complex or multi-dimensional it's
becoming really hard in a relational
database system we have all week because
we tear it apart with into all these
tables being interconnected by IDs in
Cassandra you can have like a Harley
partition set up and also Cassandra has
one of the concepts of Cassandra to get
more performance also you have a lot of
redundant data in there because it has
the primary key and only a secondary key
you cannot like in like as in relational
databases the more MongoDB like index
multiple columns or like bulky so it's
Cassandra it has a total different setup
here it's super optimized for writing
for reefer writing huge amounts of data
and so actually like I think I really
favor the document stuff because it's
that let's have a look so this is a few
if we ask for something from Cassandra
this is like the output yeah you see
like that
calm the volumes and timestamps and
Cassandra basically stores stuff as
tuples I think a graph is also like
really easy to understand then there's
some great tools out there to to to very
light graphs from neo4j so I think
graphs depending of course on the
density and other stuff but graphs I
think are really nice through to read
and understand and the relational model
it depends a lot on the table Stroman e
tables I hope so this is for example
like the comparison between relational
and document model arm and this is just
like a simple address here on the left
side so and it's already five tables
involved just for my phone number and
feel free to give me a call anytime so
it's yeah in a document model and this
is I think one of the nice things you
don't have to explain anything yeah you
can give this to any anybody okay for
name last name of course you have to
worry about the attributes you probably
use but once this is like nicely labeled
it's super simple you can pass this on
to anybody and it's it's it's really
nice because it's a lot of explaining
and communication and if communication
is involved misunderstandings will
follow it's in the nature of human
communication so there's also like nice
tools to visualize this is a tool called
compass from MongoDB you can even
visualize geographical data this is
Italy you don't see for example so you
can also use this to check data types to
get some sample like for example samples
a thousand documents you can see what is
in your database what's the distribution
of values this is an example for New
York or J you can also like visualize
graphs and check queries probably not
the most important thing for data sense
purging how to handle growth it's so
yeah it's it's it can be accomplished
it's not super hard but I think if you
want to handle growth
it's probably the time to get like a
database expert involved some more use
cases is there for storing data or
select data from outside sources is you
can even store model parameters if you
train models you can make them per
system in a database share them with
others maybe you also like distribute
the whole your whole setup of
documenting experiments um
so the conclusion here um so I hope I've
given you a good guideline for making an
educated decision on whether a database
can help you on as a tool in data
science projects so the first thing is
analyze all your real needs and focus
only on them if you work routes it's the
simplest yet go for graph database I
mean there you can so choose something
which is accessible in a simple solution
for you
yeah because likes always like these
there's like hundreds of database
systems around them many times people
across your after about this new
database and yes a well maybe be a
highly specialized system that might
help you but maybe you should really
think about it whether it's there's a
lot there's a small community maybe it's
a commercial vendor and you don't we
don't really want vendor lock-in and we
don't want like highly specialized and
depend on very maybe a startup company
with a nice idea but you also have to
think will it make will it make it
actually and do not only focus on
performance because many people only
variable performance or that's the
database performance yeah I mean like
hmm yeah so so also like I would
encourage you to try and play with the
stuff it's usually like the simple like
a simple set up is easy to install with
homebrew on a Mac or there's great
tutorials and everything so try and
choose something you feel or basically
comfortable with because like a use it
it's a tool to get stuff done
so I'd say for a good general choice if
you have just a temp table data I think
go for rich database if it's like not
complex system if you have general usage
or like a multimode dimensional
later I would really suggest have a look
at MongoDB because it makes this really
easy if you work on graphs go for neo4j
it's a graph database that's as good as
it gets
um so yeah if you knew and in the whole
database space some stuff to look into
it also like a document store again
lightens the weight of understanding
like schemas and how to do joints also
it is just a nice thing no matter what
try to take some time to later learn at
least basic SQL because it's everywhere
and you will I guarantee you will have
can reuse it and build on the knowledge
this is a very good scheme also look
into tools like SQL alchemy if you work
it's a Python a framework which can help
you on working or creating at a
relational database and basically so the
data stored as objects and distributing
all the stuff into tables SQL alchemy
takes care of that so I also want to
thank for contributing to this talk
after so to reinstate fish he's a
professor on his Island and he gave me
some really value he's like doing a lot
of stuff on database performances in
research and he gave me some really good
feedback and comments of this one this
is also like a talk in progress so if I
run into some database specialist for
very specific system I'm or a data
scientist I'm really happy to see to
hear comments and how we can improve
this okay thank you very much
any questions I think yeah really
interesting talk wondered if you could
comment on some of the other kind of
more column storage style databases like
Kudo or click house or quite modern
actually I don't know all of them
because there's just too many and um I
used to work a lot of databases but it's
not my prior promoter yep I'd not stop
my first domain so on yeah so yeah I
just like I could try and play pray with
that because there's some great stuff
also like I think if you do something
doctor I'm also like this looks like
[ __ ] chain TV to look into it so it's
it's it's there yeah yeah yeah thanks hi
thank you very much for your talk I was
just very curious about what is your
opinion on the JSON data type in
Postgres compared to using MongoDB I
think phosphorus you have to ski bar and
you can say see say this column is an
integer and you can basically predefined
everything a prompt in MongoDB you can I
think since 3 2 or 3 4 you can have like
a predefined schema MongoDB and it can
throw you a warning if the data type
does not match and it can also access
for an exception if you want to enforce
a data type usually I handle it
I use a library called Eve it's a person
library and you can predefined schemers
and also like data types which are
allowed so I usually use that validates
anything I write to the database Lea Eve
and you can have like a nice rule set
there because on some data types I
really want to be sure this is an
integer and this is so if is really
helpful and and it's really nice because
you can have it in your code and not in
a separate database configuration file
so that's an answer you know thank you
thank you
one of the use cases I've seen in data
science projects that didn't mention
your list there was creating lots of
intermediate versions of data so you
start with the clean de tourny have no
weird features and then you have some
other version of the weird features now
that's probably a problem that shouldn't
be solved in the database but I have you
seen database has been using that way
for example actually versions of tables
and I would not I would do you mean like
just all pictures on a database but
different having like different versions
of tables that represent different
features you've generated along the way
and the challenge of keeping track of
those as well I guess I'm not sure where
they get the questions so you mentioned
I guess adding a field to a document
store to say this has been processed
into particular oh okay so basically
example imagine you have them let's say
let's use something really simple we get
some data from an outsize data source
and basically the first group basically
it's just like an abstraction of jobs of
one step it's just like yeah just
getting a database AZ is just like in
maybe a document style structure and
then you can basically go to your
database and what I usually did I set
for an attribute processed just
true/false I just query for something
has this been processed or checked or
validated however you want to call it
and then just like iterate over it and
validate the data check the data um this
is like also another approach especially
if you for example I use that for web
scraping because the web scraping I
wanted to store some JC well like some
JavaScript JSON documents from a website
so it was allowed to change so it's it's
it's and the other nice thing is you can
also scale the cell so if you have a
database you can have multiple agents
querying the database and basically
pre-post process everything you have in
the pipeline oh my god thank you yep
so thank you so you mentioned that in
Postgres you can also like have like
some kind of lose equal things to the
JSON column in you experience what are
the porn cons of using like JSON format
Postgres versus using MongoDB actually I
understand it it's just like an extra
feature of off of Postgres so to lighten
so waiting in Postgres you have like
basically a basic scheme where you maybe
you are sure off and it's it's an
additional feature you have like more
like open space so I think it's a nice
combination if you have some unexpected
data so yeah it's just like a nice atom
I'm not sure about how performing to the
queering SQL Jason documents the Neil I
mean Postgres actually is um so I would
love to hear feedback from with
anybody's like Postgres super expert
here yeah thank you and if you have any
other questions are around just from
talk to me thank you
[Applause]